now i said that the dot product has many
many different applications but
kind of for the sake of time we're just
going to focus on a second one
by way of example i want you to think
back to extension one and which of that
those other results we focused on that
really heavily relied on
the dot product the dot products in
there all the time projections right so
this is going to be application
two
so um this bit's a bit tricky because
um having all come from different
classes i know
for a fact that everyone handled
projections
slightly differently and that's actually
for a good reason there's lots of
different ways
to compute projections or lots of
different formulas much like this
that are all equally valid for the
projection and just like with the dot
product in the first place
it kind of depends like which one of
these formulas will i use depends what
information
that i have some gets provided to me it
makes it easier to use like if you knew
what theta was
just go and do this one right it's much
easier right but if you don't then you
go for this one
same deal with projection so what i'm
going to ask you to do i'm going to give
you 30 seconds
and you're welcome to get the help of
the brain of the person next to you if
you like
i want you to see how many ways you can
remember
and i'll give you a spoiler there's at
least three that are all useful
how many ways do you remember to compute
the projection
of say a on to b and i'll give you a
hand just so in case you can't remember
the um
notation right when we're computing the
projection of a
onto b b is like the base vector right
so we put it down here a little bit like
in log notation that's the base of the
log so this is the base of projection
and here's the thing being projected
onto it okay
what do you remember can i give you half
a minute to
think what's in your brain jot something
down if you can jot down more than one
bonus points have a shot i'm really
happy
i see several different formulas
for the projection of a on to b and
that's great
i'm gonna go for three of them as
promised today
uh this morning that should be enough
space for now
what we're gonna do is we could sort of
go around and round for a little bit to
see what your suggestions are but
in the interest of time where i'm gonna
start with is
the one that um the one that i love in
my head the most is the one that's the
most
succinct the one that uses the least
notation that doesn't make it the best
one
but it is the easiest to remember and
where it starts
is with a dot product so the first thing
you can see here is you put in
a and then you take the dot product now
i want you to think i've given you a bit
of a clue if you've got more than one
written i want you to look at your page
which one is the shortest one which one
uses the least
symbols if you can pick that one
can you tell me what comes next xiao
yeah
b hat the unit vector
of b right does that make sense who's
got this one i haven't finished it by
the way who's got this one as one of the
ones that they've got
i like a third of the room okay good
it's not finished yet what's the what's
on the end
b hat again right yeah i always found
when i was learning these
because unlike you guys
with me 12 unlike you guys vectors was
not
in my year 11 or 12 uh maths course i
learned i was introduced to vectors at
uni right
excuse me and i remember looking at this
formula and thinking why
why so many b hats like can't we combine
these in some way and of course the
answer is no
you cannot because this thing really has
two
pieces to it i almost said components
but that's not what i mean
this thing here that was a terrible
curly brace i'm going to write it again
this thing in the brackets that dot
product right it is actually a separate
object that you learned about do you
remember
what is this thing called
it's the scalar projection if you cannot
remember this or even if you can
please label that as such this is the
scalar
projection and just to jog your memory
the whole idea is
if you've got a onto b
here's my a and b again right the idea
is if i've got a base vector
and i look at some other vector what's
the length of the shadow
this is our key metaphor right what's
the length of the shadow of
a onto b if you can imagine this ruler
casting a shadow down onto here
in an orthogonal direction right what's
the length of that shadow and a length
a length is just scalar do you remember
that okay and of course
when you do a something dot something
you just get a number out right
so there's the scalar projection out the
front and then what effect does it
produce
when we then multiply by b-hat at the
end here
fantastic it gives me the vector
projection that's the whole thing
and the way it does that is you get this
number which is a length
and then you say now apply that length
or that magnitude is maybe a better way
to say it apply that magnitude
in the direction of wherever b is going
right we make it b hat because when we
then ignore the length all you get is
the direction out of this does that make
sense
so i'm going to say apply that magnitude
the one we got in the scalar projection
apply that magnitude
in the direction of b
okay so that's great handy dandy right
but this
is not the only way to do this and
actually i'm going to suggest in
multiple contexts
even though this is nice and succinct
when you look at it it's not always the
most succinct way
to work the actual projection out and
the reason why is because
this formula is kind of cheating
cheating right um
this b-hat that appears twice right it
actually disguises
a fair bit of work right because you've
then got to calculate
uh the length of b you've got to divide
through by that
the magnitude i should have said and
then you have to multiply it by itself
here right so it gets it gets squared so
actually there's a bit of a mess of
working that's hiding underneath here
i'm going to show you exactly what that
looks like
but that's the reason why i'm about to
give you another version for this and i
hope several of you have got this
that looks looks worse but actually it's
a couple of different ones it may end up
being less work for you
so let's have a go at doing another
different form
as per uh what i rubbed off on the board
the table that's right at the start
right
um when you do a dot b one of the ways
to work out
a dot b hat one of the ways to work out
what it is is to use trigonometry
right use trigonometry so what would
that look like if i were to use the
trigonometric formula for the dot
product here
think about this in here i'm going to
say
i need the magnitude of 1 multiply by
the magnitude of the other so that would
be
in this case magnitude of a magnitude of
b hat and then what do they get
multiplied by
because of the angle between so i'm just
going to call that cos theta
and then you've got b-hat hanging out
over here okay
now the reason why this can give us
something useful
is because there's a part of this line
here that is very easy to evaluate right
which is the part that's easy to
evaluate
it's the magnitude of b hat because by
definition it's a unit vector
the magnitude of a unit vector is a it's
a it's a unit that's why i call it a
unit vector so that's their one
so what i can get is this uh magnitude
of a
cos theta and then b hat still hanging
out
the end here right so what have i got at
this moment i've got two ways
to work this out this looks a little
longer and more awkward but
as compared to the first one
right if you've got the angle between
these two
sweet just go for it use this one okay
it's going to be a bit simpler
all right so that's our second form
and then our third form i find this one
the weirdest form i'm going to write it
again
up here when i first encountered it
years and years ago i was like
why would anyone write a formula like
this
it's like i'm trying to make it hard to
remember and like obtuse and long
but it turns out this is often a very
efficient way to do it
uh i want you to remember um how did we
work out b hat again i even said it
right at the start
if you've got b how do you work out
b-hat
yeah you you divide well you're going to
work out the magnitude of b
and then you divide through by that
remember now i'm actually having to do
that twice
so watch what happens when i just kind
of include that working
in my definition what i'm going to have
here is going off of my first line
i've got this dot product right it's
going to be a
and then instead of writing b hat next
i'm going to write it's
b what am i dividing by again
magnitude b is that okay so that's there
and then and then i do the same thing
i've got b hat out the end
here as well here's b divided by
its magnitude great now the reason why
this ends up being useful to me is hold
up for a second
these are just scalars do you agree so
because they're just scalars you can
just kind of factor them out
you can sort of move them wherever is
appropriate to yourself so what i can do
is i can say
oh i've got uh a dot
b up here in the top so far so good
on the denominator these two scalars
here
i can combine them now it's not
immediately obvious why combining them
might be useful but i want you to think
about
how is it what formula do i use to work
out the magnitude of any vector
we did it here i'm doing pythagoras
which involves square roots
but because you're squaring a square
root you're like oh things will just
come out in the wash right so think
about this maybe you want to put this do
i have an appropriate color here we go
then you want to put this off on the
side here right um
i'll sneak it in here if we were to work
this out
what i'm doing is i'm working out the
magnitude which is the square root of
you take each of these components right
uh the x
and the y and the b
right you've got that right and then you
square that thing do you agree so this
gets rid of the square root
so if you have a look at what's
underneath the square root sign
underneath the radical sign is actually
the proper name
you're multiplying the x component of b
by itself and the y component of b by
itself and the z component
of b by itself uh we have a way to do
that right we have
much more succinct notation for doing
that it actually looks like
on the denominator here you're taking
the dot product of a vector
against itself because you're comparing
the x's
and the y's and the z's with yourself
right
so that's why oh i'm just going to sneak
it in on here we can write the
denominator as b
dot b and whoever wrote this
formula obviously b was their favorite
letter of the alphabet
and you can see why when you first look
at this you're like why
why would you do this like this looks so
nice and neat but the whole point is
this makes easier like you see this mess
that i dealt i had i have to deal with
if i use the unit vector form is going
to be easier to deal with here
okay so can i ask you to write down
a pair of vectors for me in column form
4 2 negative 3 4
2 negative 3. i'll write this down
shortly i just need to make space for
myself
that's vector a and vector b is going to
be
i'll give you a nice and easy one
negative 1
1 1. so
a is 4 2 negative 3 excuse me
and b is negative 1 positive 1 positive
1.
can you go ahead and work out the
projection of a
onto b for me you've got three formulas
here you can use here's one here's two
and here's three you can use whichever
one you like
in fact if you get there quickly i'd
like you to try and use more than one
so that you can confirm for me that they
all work right i mean hopefully we're
content that this is true
but have a go whichever one you think is
the easiest go for it and then try a
second one
whichever one you want all right i'm
pretty happy
i've gone around and i've seen uh i've
seen people
attempt their second use of a second
formula one two three you can choose
um which is a good sign and maybe you're
starting to see the comparison you're
like oh i know eventually i'm doing the
same amount of work
but is is i am am i more geared towards
one
than the other i'm going to do this in
kind of reverse order
i'm actually going to go straight to my
third one here and some people use a
slightly different version of this
formula which is fine we'll get the same
result
i've got a and i've got b i don't i'm
not given the angle
between them i can go ahead and work out
the unit vector
for b it's not difficult but let's see
what happens if we just use this third
one here because i'm highlighting how
funny it looks
but watch how it works out a dot b on b
dot b
times b let's have a go i'm in column
form
right so can you tell me what am i going
to get on my numerator here when i do
the dot product
a dot b
i'm going to get yep negative 4
plus 2 minus 3. cool and you can
obviously simplify that in a second on
my denominator
i'm going to do b against itself so it's
actually just everything squared do you
agree
so it's just going to be in this case
one plus one plus one
even if they were a messy number it's
not hard to just square everything is
that okay
and then i then just say the b vector
along the end here which is negative 1
1 done does that make sense now i think
it is really important by the way and i
noticed this i was walking around
some people have gone straight to
simplifying this fraction out the front
and very likely i've actually done it
correctly
i still don't like it i don't want you
to jump to
here's my answer straight away because
again so many times the recent
assessment was a good
reminder of this right number one if you
get this wrong and i just see your
simplified version it's just flat
wrong i can't see if you actually knew
what you were doing and made some minor
error
okay secondly i want you to communicate
that i can see where this came from i
instantly can tell
oh this person was doing two dot
products i i know what formula they were
using because
you've got many to choose from does this
make sense so even though it is
materially easy to work out that this is
going to be what
in front what's our coefficient negative
5 on 3. even though it's i think pretty
easy for a lot of you to do that in your
head i'm going to encourage you
not to okay there's my answer are you
happy with that